Hey David, you mentioned after the last democratic
debate that you thought Tom Stier did better
than a number of the other candidates on stage.
Who would you rather have as president Tom
Stier, Joe Biden or Pete Buddha?
Judge, I am going to take a position that
might anger some people or, or maybe some
people will appreciate it if you say the next
president, uh, or the next nominee, the nominee
to face off against Trump will be booted,
judge Biden or Stier.
I think I go with Stier in, in both of those
scenarios.
Now there are people who are opposed to Stier
because he's a billionaire.
Uh, okay.
And we can sort of have that debate.
Pete Buddha judge doesn't have a lot of money.
Joe Biden is a reasonably wealthy and a sire
is extremely wealthy.
Stire basically has the right positions or
at least as good of a position as Biden and
booted judge on almost every issue.
He wants to get rid of capital punishment.
He wants to end, uh, um, he, uh, wants to
end the disparity between, uh, Coke, the cocaine
sentencing disparity, which is a very racialized
issue.
He wants to get rid of mandatory minimum sentences.
He wants to get rid of private prisons.
He wants mandated paper ballots for election
security.
He wants to do a lot in terms of affordable
housing.
He supports broad paid leave for everyone
several months.
He believes that there should not be unlimited
spending allowed in politics on campaigns.
He wants to end new oil and gas leases on
federal land and offshore drilling.
Okay.
His position on healthcare is not the best,
but remember, Biden's position on healthcare
is not great.
Buddha judge's position on healthcare isn't
great, and I like the energy of Stier better
than Biden's, which is almost no energy and
better than booted judge's sort of like ultra
rehearsed weirdness, um, PO STI or has some
other positions that I like, uh, on assault
weapons.
He wants to do a voluntary buy back program,
which could actually get a lot of guns off
the streets.
He wants universal background checks.
He wants a national firearm registry, which
a lot of candidates hesitate to say, um, he
wants to do Medicare drug price negotiations.
I mean, it's a long list and he would bring
an energy that Joe Biden is completely lacking.
And, uh, that is to me, a more palatable energy
than what Pete booted judge brings.
So I want to hear from you.
If these are the three choices Stier Biden
or Buddha judge, who do you go with also in
imagining how they would face up against Donald
Trump?
I think Joe Biden would not do well in debates
against Donald Trump.
Biden used to be a great debate or check out
his old debates with Paul Ryan.
Excellent.
I mean ran circles around the guy made him
look like a real fool, made him look like
an uninformed kid essentially.
But he doesn't seem to have it at this point
in time.
Booted.
Judge would, you know, he always says, if
I were to Buddha, Jonah says, if I were to
debate Trump, I could say I served where you
got out because of a bone spurs letter.
That might be powerful, but that'll last like
30 seconds and then they'll move on to other
stuff.
And I think Trump has the potential of making
Pete Buddha judge look kind of dumb.
I think Stier of the three does the best in
debates against Donald Trump as well.
This is not an endorsement of satire.
I don't plan to vote for Stier but if you
gave me only those three options, I think
I'm going with Tom Stier.
Let me know what you think.
Let me know if I'm crazy.
Have I lost my mind to say that?
I want to hear from you.